I'm joined by retired lieutenant general Mark
hurtling CNS Katie Beau lillis and former U.S
ambassador to Ukraine William Taylor General
hurtling let me start with you how big of a
breakthrough potentially is this if both the U.S
and Germany start sending tanks to Ukraine and
how long could it actually take until the uh the
Abrams battle tanks the U.S tanks are actually
on the battlefield for Ukraine here's what I've
said uh wolf I think the the leopards the Leos
will probably be there a lot faster I'm going
to predict two to three months that they will be
in the field in combat primarily because they're
in Europe already you have 13 countries that are
part of NATO and partners of NATO that had the
Leo battle tank there's only one right now and
that's the United States that has the Abrams the
the Poland is going to get the Abrams thing but
that's a little bit uh time off what we will see
though is Ben's comment about the establishment
of the logistics and the supply lines to these
vehicles the Leo runs on a diesel tank it's much
easier to repair it's much easier to maintain that
Abrams has as you know that multi-fuel turbine
engine that has a lot of different moving Parts
could be more significant so what I would predict
is you'll see the Leos on the battlefield within
two to three months the Abrams are probably going
to be a lot longer I'd Place those sometimes six
to eight months out before they can establish not
only the training capability for the cruise but
the unit capabilities as well as the establishment
of the sustainment approach to the to the Abrams
you know Ambassador Taylor as you know Russia has
been warning for months and months warning that
the Iranian people Ukrainian people I should
say will pay the price uh uh if the West starts
sending these tanks to Ukraine what message does
this expected decision by both Germany and the U.S
send to Putin and how do you think he may respond
well no one knows how he's going to respond wolf
um and frankly um he has said and his people have
said over and over they're going to do things
if we send more weapons and they've never done
that so this is exactly the right decision um
this is this is what we should be doing this
is exactly the kind of thing that we should be
sending to the to the ukrainians by the way I
understand that uh secretary Austin um had
a lot to do did a lot of work last week in
uh in Germany at very high levels to get this
deal so secretary Austin gets a lot of credit
for this and I don't think he was much bothered
by anything that the Russians are saying a good
point you know Katie Beau I know you're doing a
lot of reporting on this uh what is your latest
reporting on this message from U.S officials
to president zielinski on Ukrainian tactics
uh just ahead of an expected major Russian
military offensive coming in the coming weeks
well if U.S officials have been quietly urging
the ukrainians to take a step back from this
incredibly costly artillery and infantry fight
that they have been waging against the Russians
in the eastern city of bakmut now for months in
lieu of a more mechanized counter-offensive to
try to reclaim some territory in the South which
coincidentally is exactly the kind of fight that
the leopard twos would be ideally suited for
there's there's a sense within the US government
right now that Ukraine has a window of opportunity
in the spring to try to retake some territory in
the South before Russia is able to rearm regroup
to to mobilize additional forces but there's a
sense that they would need to essentially cut
their losses in bakmut in order to do that and
it's not clear that Ukraine would want to do that
even though buckmut is not seen as strategically
significant to the overall fight it has become
symbolically important to the ukrainians and so
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski is sort of
caught in between a couple of competing priorities
here politically he may have a difficult time
backing away from the fight in bhakmat even
if it is not seen as a terribly important
strategic priority for Ukraine good point
Katie balilis thank you very much special thanks
also to retired lieutenant general Mark hurtling
and former U.S ambassador William Taylor will stay
on top of this story very significant development